[Musique]
dupont-aignan nicolas 61 ans candidate
de goût la france à l'élection
présidentielle c'est votre troisième
campagne nous allons voyager ensemble
dans les archives de l'ina pour tenter
de cerner votre adn bonjour nicolas
dupont aignan bonjour monsieur la
première fois que vous apparaissez à la
télévision vous êtes sous préfet
d'ile-de-france et vous devez gérer une
situation de crise le relogement de
familles africaines sans abri qui
campent sur un terrain vague le futur
site de la bibliothèque nationale de
france nous sommes en 91 vrai 30 ans
les premiers expulsés avaient planté
leurs tentes le 13 juin sur un terrain
vague de la ville de paris s'était vite
devenu un village africain maliens
sénégalais et un bras de fer à trois
avec la ville de paris et les pouvoirs
publics
mais l'hiver approche peu de chauffage
de nombreux enfants manque d'hygiène
malgré l'aide des associations et il y a
deux semaines dans l'attentes 85 des
rats ont même mordu deux enfants alors
sans vouloir céder l'état a voulu
chercher à sortir de l'impasse
expérimentés ainsi un système de
logement passerelle il n'y a pas de
prime au logement pour une occupation
illicite simplement il ya un devoir
d'assistance pour des familles qui sont
dans une situation aujourd'hui très
douloureuse à l'avenir quand il aura une
expulsion les personnes qui ne trouvera
pas ne trouveront pas de logement
pourront aller dans des logements de
d'insertion provisoire gérés par des
associations caritatives grâce à un
nouveau financement de la part de l'état
le relogement de familles immigrées
c'était par conviction par devoir
parler d'eux enfin le bar de voir
j'étais serviteur de l'état je me
souviens très bien c'était la première
intervention j'étais avec un grand
préfet deux grands préfet et christian
philip et puis
sauter question dans cette et olivier
philippe et christian sautter et et il
était tiraillée entre la volonté de pas
faire passer des familles devant
d'autres et puis en même temps de
répondre à une situation humanitaire il
m'avait envoyé au feu parce que je crois
que personne personne voulait intervenir
lors il avait trouvé le petit jeune de
services donc à la fois par deux voire
par conviction et par gt serviteur de
l'état vous devenez mer en 95 à hier
l'essonne puis député deux ans plus tard
sous les couleurs du rpr votre
permanence c'est l'arrière d'une
camionnette
nicolas dupont aignan et maire de la
ville de yerres dans l'essonne mais
c'est en tant que député il sillonne sa
circonscription à la rencontre de ses
concitoyens
son bureau une camionnette c'est sa
papamobile à lui
ça me permet d'aller où je veux quand je
veux au moment on le souhaite on
m'appelle ça permet d'avoir un peu comme
ce cargo sa coquille sur soi déjà une
circonscription à se ramasser mais avec
des quartiers très divers des mers plus
ou moins coopératif il faut qu'il
s'habitue et donc ça me permet d'être un
peu libre une forme de liberté de l'élu
cette papamobile ou du pont mobile elle
a servi longtemps très longtemps
elle est maintenant complètement
usé mais j'ai adoré cette période est
gelée continuer à chaque élection même
la dernière parce que j'ouvrais les
portes dans tous les quartiers et si je
suis un homme politique je pense
différent des autres c'est parce que
j'ai toujours gardé les pieds sur terre
et j'ai été réélu j'ose pas dire nombre
de fois à la surprise de tous les
observateurs parisiens parce que ils ne
connaissent pas le travail d'écouté et
de des changes que je fais dans une
circonscription qui a toujours été
plutôt de gauche même communiste allons
à présent déterré vos racines
il paraît que dans votre jeunesse quand
vous passiez devant l'assemblée
nationale avec vos parents vous aviez
envie d'aller voir ce qui se passait à
l'intérieur
alors je vous propose la visite guidée
de léon zitrone en 1958 à l'intention
des futurs députés de la toute jeune
vème république
mais entrons maintenant dans le palais
auguste pour une promenade imaginé pour
nous pas regagné le break
dans la salle des séances la tribune des
arts à terre l'histoire ces tablettes à
la main note vos paroles de la renommée
a embouché la trompette de votre gloire
derrière vous le président regard de
l'assemblée il distingue la droite de la
gauche par rapport à sa tribune la même
cloche servant à diriger toutes les
pensées vagabondent ans par trop voici
la salle des pas perdus 20 mètres sur 11
plus loin la salle des quatre colonnes
où vous trouverez le nom de vos
prédécesseurs mais pour la france rien
n'a bougé légende ou réalité c'est
vraiment en passant devant l'assemblée
que vous avez eu envie de faire de la
politique non j'ai toujours eu envie
c'est très curieux d'ailleurs c'est très
étrange était pas du tout d'une famille
politique
pas du tout j'étais famille de classe
moyenne et méchés pas j'avais 10 ans je
sais pas comment vous dis à chaque fois
que je passais devant l'assemblée je me
disais mais je veux entrer là je veux
être et luge
c'est impensable que je sois pas élu et
mes parents me disaient mais notre
enfant est dingue
comment il va il n'y arrivera jamais il
ne pourra pas et à chaque fois je
passais dans à l'assemblée j'avais
l'impression que je devais être là c'est
bizarre et puis je l' ai tellement
espéré j'ai été élu très jeune quand
même à 36 ans là aussi à la surprise
générale et
j'ai été tellement déçu dessous de voir
ce qu'est devenue cette assemblée député
très jeune et militant très jeune
puisque 13 ans vous collait des affiches
pour jacques chaban-delmas
candidat gaulliste à la présidentielle
de 74
nous rajeunit pas c'est littéralement
porté par une foule en délire que
jacques chaban delmas a gagné hier soir
la tribune dressée dans le grand hall du
palais de la fois près de deux heures
d'attentes n'avait pas entamé la bonne
humeur et l'enthousiasmé des quelques
7000 personnes et depuis 19h avaient
pris place dans l'enceinte banderole
déployée panneaux brandis badge à la
boutonnière en sautoir ils étaient tous
là
jacques chaban-delmas prend la parole
les planeurs ne se sont pas encore tue
voulez une france en paix avec elle même
et avec les autres je le maintiendrai
vous voulez une france plus juste plus
solidaire plus humaine je les construire
est avec vous
qu'est ce qui plaisait chez chaban aux
jeunes aux tout jeunes adolescents que
vous étiez nicolas dupont aignan le
gaullisme social que j'ai retrouvé après
chez philippe séguin c'est pour moi si
vous voulez personne peut comprendre ce
que je suis si on ne comprend pas que
pour moi mon patriotisme ma défense de
la nation
s'explique par la démocratie et par
l'exception sociale française voilà ça
me fait penser à romain gary qui disait
toujours je n'aime pas la france tout le
monde hier à il aime pas la france
j'aime la france libre c'est ça mon adn
ça c'est mon message il était très jeune
très jeune dès 13 ans est à 13 ans avant
13 ans je me souviens que je suis parti
j'avais un copain qui aimait beaucoup la
politique en classe je pense qu'elle a
des on était parti en angleterre on
avait 12 ans et on commentait dans le
train le programme commun de la gauche
vous imaginez à 12 ans j'ai eu la
passion de la politique à 10 11 ans
vraiment et mes parents n'avaient pas la
télévision quand j'étais petit il était
hostile je pouvais pas de télévision
j'en avais un complexe immense à l'école
c'est horrible à l'école j'étais à des
rares on n'avait pas la télé et j'en
étais tellement malheureux qu'à un
moment mes parents ont loué une
télévision et je regardais le mercredi
le jeudi ou mercredi les questions au
gouvernement qui pour la première fois
été retransmise à la télévision elle et
tous les mercredis gt ou jeudi chez plus
et c'était mercredi ou jeudi c'est la
première fois vous retrouvez à la date
et j'étais arrivé devant l'écran me
disant c'est ça que je veux faire cesser
et pourtant pas du tout d'une famille de
sa me regarder comme une espèce de
soucoupe volante d'ovni
et même ma mère n'a jamais été content
que je fasse de la politique elle était
très fière quand j'ai eu l'énorme que je
sois sous-préfet elle en était fier et
le jour où je lui ai dit moi ça mange en
prend un autre mot ça m'embête cette
carrière d'abord je peux pas parler je
vais me faire virer parce que je ne peux
pas supporter de beer comme ça et je
vais me lance je veux être élue elle m'a
dit mais pourquoi pourquoi mais c'est
pas possible tu vas être malheureux ne
fait jamais ça enfin c'était un drame
pour ma mère qui était fier choix sous
préfet mais quelle quand j'ai été élu
député et on fichait complètement alors
justement l'ena après sciences po cursus
classique du futur commis de la
république l'école nationale
d'administration et ces énarques ainsi
présenté dans un numéro de sangles
colonnes à la une en 1966
moi personnellement je crois que j'ai
j'avais envie de lyon de m'occuper un
peu du destin des autres l'anchois qu'à
ce moment là on a le choix entre trois
quarts entre trois carrières militaires
par exemple curé ou administrateurs
militaire j'ai pas tellement définitive
de la vente et de la location pure et
non plus donc j'ai choisi un peu
administrateurs et frais votre
définition du leader moderne
c'est un chef qui essaient de s'engager
au maximum de sa brigade cécile dans la
pas essayer de les imposer de rudes et
ses idées soient pour la porte par la
persuasion c'est à savoir écouter aussi
nous deux je crois que ce serait une
meilleure définition des pigalle humide
voire nous intéresse plus que l'argent
si vous voulez d'une certaine manière on
suit le pouvoir
j'ai pensé oh regardez les mobiles les
mobiles des élèves qui travaillent à
l'ena il est assez longtemps des quatre
ans les mobiles à des numérotées en
mettant le pouvoir l'argent le succès de
personnel etc cinéma
le pouvoir serait sans doute passé
alors entre le serviteur de l'état le
jeune un peu prétentieux qui se rêve en
leader ou qui parlent des leaders et la
vide de pouvoir dans lequel de ces
personnages vous reconnaissez vous
moi j'ai fait l'ena parce que j'étais
pas d'une famille de la politique
classes moyennes ni pauvre ni riche pas
de relation aucune relation et pour moi
c'était le moyen peut-être d'accéder à
un monde qui n'était pas le mien
c'était sa part le mérite donc j'ai j'ai
été très heureux à sciences po parce que
j'étais heureux j'étais très malheureux
l ena parce que je suis arrivé dans un
dans un monde qui n'était pas le mien
parce qu'ils étaient trop
trop conformistes disons et mais j'étais
fier parce que c'était un moyen de
méritocratie républicaine alors je suis
le pur produit d'une méritocratie
républicaine que deux classes moyennes
favorisé par défavorisés parce que faut
pas jouer mais disons simple mais pas du
tout dans le milieu voilà et puis
j'avais le culte de l'état quand même
j'ai lu de go le richelieu j'étais un
passionné d'histoire et pour moi la
france est indissociable de sa colonne
vertébrale qui est l etat et puis en
arrivant à l'ena et après en préfecture
j'ai compris qu'il y avait que l'état
était déjà abîmée si je suis arrivé
vraiment dans la période de mitterrand
diène de l'argent roi comment s'est
hélas pour moi j'ai une déception très
profonde l'état de l'état et je me suis
dit que par la politique qu'on pourra
rétablir la nation et l'état
dans les racines de chacun il y à un
patronyme est dans le vôtre il y à
dupont l'un des noms français les plus
courants alors je vous laisse apprécier
ce reportage de 1952 trouvait dans la
malle aux trésors de l'ina rejet est pas
né quand vous vous expliquerez après pas
pourquoi vous vous appelez non pas du
pont mais dupont aignan
et vous madame dupont vous parlez les 21
millions 400 mille madame dupont qui je
suis une bonne française moyenne madame
dupont se marie en moyenne à 24 aux
ailes à environ 15% de chances de
divorcer au bout de trois ans
hélas 30% de chances d'être trompée au
bout de cinq ans
76% de madame dupont apporté ton lit le
petit déjeuner de leur mari sauf pendant
700 premiers mois de leur mariage ou 45%
de messieurs dupont emprise cet office
voilà pour ce monsieur et madame dupont
archétype de français moyens alors
pourquoi dupont aignan tout simplement
parce que quand je suis arrivé en
maternelle ma mère m'emmenait à la
maternelle il y avait un autre nicolas
dupont qui était inscrit à ma place est
en fait j'étais pas inscrits puisque
quand ma mère m'avait inscrire lui avait
dit oh oui y'a pas de problème mais en
fait c'était un autre donc nous étions
de nicolas dupont n'est quasiment la
même date c'est parce qu'il est devenu
d'air et donc ma mère a dit ma mère
était assez féministe et elle a dit on
va mettre mon nom avec le nom de mon
mari est comme ça il va s'appeler dupont
aignan est la maîtresse a dit c'est très
bien comme ça j'ai vite fait de les
confondre et puis c'est resté comme ça
j'ai fait toute ma scolarité avec ce
double nom qui n'était pas le mien en
fait parce que c'était pas autorisées à
l'époque ce n'était pas autorisée et ça
a été que je crois sous mitterrand 80
que j'ai pu accoler le nom légalement
le nom d' usage voilà c'est voilà c'est
tout c'est tout con est ce qu'il y
aurait une logique selon vous à ce qu'un
dupont devienne président de la
république j'en sais rien cela j'en sais
rien
c'est pas pour ça il n'y a pas de
déterminisme parler non non quoi qu'en
disent certains candidats je crois au
contraire que chacun forges le seul
regret que j'ai c'est que mes filles
n'est pas mon nom
puisque l on du pont avec le nom de leur
mère à quelques pas aussi bon mais c'est
vous savez moi je crois je suis très
républicain dans cet esprit je crois que
et aventurier en fait parce que j'avais
une mère qui était très libre d'esprit
j'ai eu des parents j'ai de la chance
parce que j'aurais pu avoir des parents
d'une moyenne bourgeoisie étriqué et qui
était pas du tout étriqué qui était
d'une moyenne bourgeoisie très libre on
parlait de tout j'avais un grand père
aviateur de 14 on était quand même
j'avais un bain familial je ne gagnais
pas dans l'argent mais je baignais dans
la culture et dans la liberté et c'est
peut-être ce qui m'a entraîné parfois
avoir des
décisions audacieuses si on est positif
on y reviendra sûrement voyons à présent
qu'ils sont vos mentors
avec votre combat contre l'europe de
maastricht où vous avez mis vos pas dans
ceux de philippe séguin vous l'avez cité
tout à l'heure ses gains qui a mené
cette bataille des 92 au sein du rpr
j'ai le droit de dire qu'il est des
moments où il faut savoir dire oui ou
non au lieu de se réfugier dans le ni ni
j'ai le droit de dire que je ne veux pas
manger mon chapeau l'europe de
maastricht marche sur la tête il nous
faut la remettre sur ses pieds pour
continuer d'avancer alors qu'est ce qui
lie à frileux dans cette démarche qu'est
ce qu'il y a de rétrograde qu'est ce qui
lie à d'archéo à vouloir bâtir l'europe
à partir des réalités nationales
vous ne considérez comme l'un de vos
mentors à jeux gc le sol la seule
personnalité politique que j'ai connu
que j'adorais que je respectais que
j'admirais et quelle tragédie pour la
france que cet homme
n'ait pas pu faire plus c'était le seul
homme d'état dans un milieu denain et de
médias cre le seul nom a vraiment vous
avez vous avez côtoyé d'autres pas photo
mais pas photos personnages de ce
courant de pensée sans mépris pour
beaucoup d'autres ascquois villiers dans
mon psy pasqua qui était quelqu'un de
très attachant mais pasqua
pasqua mais mes philippe séguin avait la
structure intellectuelle exceptionnelle
il avait simplement une petite fragilité
pour s'affirmer paradoxalement et si
vous si j'ai pris tant de position
parfois audacieuses si j'ai rompu les
amarres si j'étais candidat c'est parce
que j'ai été traumatisé mais vraiment
quand je les ai connus en 95 je me
souviens un jour je le vois dans les
couloirs de l'assemblée était président
de l'assemblée après le combat de
maastricht j'étais jeune collaborateur
chez barnier et je lui dis monsieur le
président mais présente et vous
ne laissez pas chirac et balladur ce
combat mais présentez vous ayez le
courage d'y aller pourquoi vous n'allez
pas vous avez tout pour y aller et il
s'est dégonflé à ce moment là il fallait
qu'il y aille voilà c'est un immense
regret c'est le seul jeu ne serait
effectuée pour sega j'ai écrit de ses
discours il demandait à plusieurs
personnes bas vreizh paul marie coûteaux
karoutchi moi on était étudiant et puis
j'ai gardé vraiment je pense que quand
ils étaient exclus de tout j'allais le
voir dans son petit bureau au dessus de
la porte de l'assemblée et il me disait
il me racontait un peu tout le monde je
crois que j'étais un des rares et sa
secrétaire plan témoigner à venir alors
que j'ai aucun intérêt personne n'avait
plus d'intérêt tout le monde l'a laissé
tomber mais alors vous mener une double
vie parce qu en
93-94 vous l'avez rappelé vous avez
servi deux ministres très pro européens
comme conseiller technique de françois
bayrou puis de michel barnier vous errez
malheureux mais je savais qu'en ces
années deux ans ils le savaient de
camions ou j'ai mené une double vie
c'est quand j'étais à la préfecture et à
la préfecture de l'île de france où je
mener une action d'ailleurs que je
trouvais honorable qui était le schéma
directeur de l'aménagement de la région
ile de france
sous un grand préfet socialiste et
christian sautter et que j'admirais
beaucoup sous michel rocard et ces deux
là on a dit que j'étais rocardien mais
en fait je servais l'état et le soir
j'écrivais les discours de ses gains
et puis après j'ai été candidat 95 avant
d'être candidat à 95 g/t en cabinet
michel berger bayrou barnier et j'étais
en désaccord profond sur l'europe bien
sûr mais barnier à l'époque avait pas
viré sa cuti pro-européenne c'est après
95 j'étais déjà parti j'étais maire de
ma ville mais tout le monde savait que
j'étais le que j'étais un admirateur de
philippe seguin tout le monde savait il
n'y a pas de secret pour ces gars c'est
un regret vraiment c'est un regret
profond pour le pays et puis après il
est mort de chagrin il est mort de
chagrin je peux le dire
en 2014 vous fondez votre parti debout
la fav en 2009 2009 ça s'appelait debout
la république oui mais je quitte je
quitte l'ump sur la tresse que j'y
croyais la possibilité de faire la
campagne du non au référendum en 2005
on me la laisse le faire sarkozy est
très correct parce qu'il sait qu'il a
besoin aussi des gens qui votent non
pour 2007
et puis en 2007 quand il me dit dans le
secret de son bureau on en a rien à
[ __ ] du référendum on fera voter un
traité par le parlement qui reviendra
sur le non des français
là je m'en vais et je quitte ça
s'appelait l'ump j'ai pris ça s'appelait
l'ump en 2007 je quitte parce que je ne
peux pas accepter que la parole du
peuple qui a voté non au référendum soit
trahi et ça c'est pas possible pour moi
et je prend tous les risques parce que
je quitte je me retrouve tout seul
quelques vieux militant gaulliste et ont
créé debout la république qui se
transforment en de nous la france après
et donc votre cible numéro un dans cette
nouvelle phase de votre vie politique
l'europe et sa monnaie l'euro
la vie chère c'est l'euro
les délocalisations
c'est l'heure où le chômage
c'est l'euro
la misère et la pauvreté c'est l'euro
s'il ya plus de choix budgétaires autant
donner la clé du parlement du président
de la république à la commission des
commissaires des commissaires c'est à
dire une dictature est ce que l'euro
fonctionne et marchent bien tout le
monde sait que non on veut faire passer
aujourd'hui exactement le même texte
sans consulter les français moi
j'appelle ça un coup d'état fait la
première fois depuis la libération que
le parlement français va voter un traité
qui a été refusée solennellement par le
peuple français deux ans avant
donc c'est plus qu'un vol c'est un viol
moi j'appelle les 16 millions de
français des lecteurs français qui ont
voté non en 2005 à ne pas se laisser
faire alors mais ce qu'on voit la
souffrance des européens réduisent sont
à mener une mauvaise politique
européenne se veut pas dire que vous
être contre l'europe il fallait
construire l'europe sur des bases
beaucoup plus cela leur faut rendre à la
france sa liberté il faut qu'elles
puissent se protéger il faut qu'elle ait
sa monnaie il faut qu'elle soit libre de
ses moyens sinon on continuera dans la
ruine avec ce poison nous allons
on a eu l'embarras du choix pour
composer sa eu ce florilège
mais nicolas dupont aignan ça n'a pas
vraiment pris dans l'opinion est ce que
vous reconnaissez que l'euro est une
certaine idée européenne ont fini par
s'imposer l' esclavage de la france là
je persiste et je peux je ne retire pas
un mot de ce que j'ai dit même sur la
monnaie européenne mais bien sûr
d'ailleurs vous verrez que ça ne tiendra
pas si longtemps que l'on croit c'est
impossible donc c'est ça et et c'est
pour ça que philippe séguin avait raison
et qu'on a je persiste à penser que nous
avions raison
c'est l' esclavage de la france sa
misère sa pauvreté tout a été écrit dans
le disco pour la france de philippe
seguin cependant moi qui ai inventé tout
ça et ça s'applique et c'est terrible
parce que les français
finalement ont été enfermés là dedans on
voit le déficit commercial cette année
83 milliards dont plus de la moitié avec
nos partenaires voilà c'est une machine
à broyer le pays
un jour on s'en apercevra quand mais je
ne regrette rien parce que je le pense
je le pense toujours
d'ailleurs toute ma campagne de 2002 22
2017 2022 et puis 2022 2000 serait 2022
va être faite là-dessus
pas obligatoire alors sur l'euro il y
aura une adaptation parce que c'est
tellement rentrée dans les moeurs qui va
falloir organiser une flexibilité mais
d'ailleurs ce qui est intéressant c'est
que le nouveau président de la banque
centrale a fait ce que j'avais
recommandé est ce que trichet voulait
pas faire quand il y avait ces paroles
c'est à dire qu'il à monétiser à mort
pour assouplir le système donc pouvoir
acceptable aujourd'hui le système non il
va l'état il n'est pas durable il est
transitoirement acceptable parce que je
pense et c'est ce que je dirai pour
cette élection je pense que d'abord il
faut retrouver nos frontières faut
retrouver la supériorité de nos lois
faut déjà aller et faut déjà colmater
les brèches et puis sur l'euro on aura
le bras de fer avec l'allemagne et soit
l'allemagne accepte qu'on monétise et
c'est nous qui piègeront l'allemagne
soit l'allemagne refuse et
eh bien les pays du sud sont obligés
d'inventer autre chose donc de toutes
façons il n'y a pas d'exemple d'union
monétaire qui dure sur des bases qui
sont pas solides donc les faits me
donneront raison malheureusement c'est
beaucoup de chômage de souffrance de
perte de richesse pour la france et et
je suis candidat parce que je pense et
je serai le seul candidat là en 2022 qui
graissent sur cette ligne qu'on réglera
les problèmes du pays que si on retrouve
notre indépendance voilà et maintenant
un grand homme va vous parler qu'il est
souvent cité invoqué dans cette campagne
vous voici face à de gaulle non
avec une séquence que nous avons choisi
pour vous elle date de 1967
ont maintenant 10 qu'elle se serait que
la pré grille
et bien c'est par là que nous avons
terminé
tout a toujours une fin et chacun se
termine
au moment ce n'est pas le cas
[Musique]
de toute façon après de gaulle c'est
peut-être ce soir
où l'un six mois ou dans un an
ça peut être dans cinq ans
puisque c'est là le terme que fixent la
con solution au mandat qui lui est
confié
mais
si je voulais faire rire quelques-uns ou
enfer brenier d'autres je dirais que je
peux je suis à durer encore dix ans 15
franchement je ne le pense pas qu'est-ce
que d'euros de gaulle aurait pensé de
ceux qui se prétendent ses héritiers
parce que lui semble considérer que
après lui finalement
il se passera pas grand chose il y aura
pas grand chose
il ne peut pas en avoir parce que
personne ne peut égaler cette grandeur
et cette force en revanche
est d'ailleurs ceux qui s'en réclament
souvent sont ceux qui l'ont plus le plus
trahis dans les faits et notamment le
parti dit gaulliste qui était le rpr
puis l'ump donc là dessus c'est pourquoi
j'en suis parti mais pour autant je
pense qu'on a quand même le droit de
tirer les leçons de ce qui s'est passé
non pas pour imiter mais simplement pour
en tirer les leçons il ya quelques
points cardinaux pour moi il y en a
quatre l'esprit de résistance on doit
pouvoir tout abandonner pour une
conviction le deuxième point c'est la
souveraineté du peuple c'est le peuple
qui doit décider c'est pas les
oligarchies nous sommes en oligarchie
est aujourd'hui troisième point c'est un
humanisme
nimani c'est à dire c'est pas la france
pour la france c'est ce que je vous dis
au départ de ces la france d'égalité
sociale la participation sept grands
échecs de de gaulle parce que les
syndicales patronales ont tué et puis et
puis c'est le quatrième point qui va
vous surprendre c'est une vision de
l'avenir c'est à dire que c'était un
géant parce qu'il avait une anticipation
notamment par exemple sur ce qu'on vit
aujourd'hui avec l'ukraine sur la mule
un monde multipolaire c'est à dire des
grands blocs la chine etc
on est revenu dans l'alliance atlantique
on s'est rétréci au moment où on devrait
épouser le monde avec la francophonie
voilà pour moi c'est ça le gaullisme
alors ça s'appellera autrement si un
jour il ya un homme d'état en france
voilà qui arrive au pouvoir parce que le
problème le problème c'est comme
aujourd'hui c'est comme si on demandait
à de gaulle de se faire élire par vichy
ça c'est dur en fait on demande aux
gaullistes de se faire élire dans le
régime de vichy c'est pas facile c'est
le régime de vichy aujourd'hui pas la
même chose mais dans l'esprit
c'est un esprit d'abandon la france les
dirigeants français sont devenus des
oligarques qui ont abandonné
l'indépendance du pays je le pense et
quand ça a été pareil sous les anglais
sous jeanne d'arc enfin quand jeanne
d'arc combattait ça a été paré de tous
ces régimes où les dirigeants sont
vendus à l'étranger voilà moi j'estime
que nos dirigeants ont vendu le pays à
l'étranger voilà donc je vous le dis
comme je le pense alors plus ou moins
alors on peut le vendre pour de l'argent
on peut le vendre pour une idéologie
abominable 7 est vicié c'était bien pire
attention ne mélangez pas mais c'est cet
esprit de la soumission on ne défend
plus l'intérêt du peuple on défend des
privilèges et des oligarques c'est la
france macro nist
la rubrique suivante
180 degrés comme les revirements ou
volte face qui émaillent tous les
parcours politique avec ce coup de
théâtre en 2017 après avoir recueilli 4
7% des voix au premier tour de la
présidentielle
vous vous ranger au côté de marine le
pen pour le second tour
c'est l'image que marine le pen espérait
depuis des jours s'afficher aux côtés de
nicolas dupont aignan avec à la clé un
accord de gouvernement une première dans
l'histoire du front national la
candidate puis fait une promesse
présidente de la république je nommerai
nicolas dupont aignan premier ministre
de la france appuyé par une majorité
présidentielle cohérente et unis par
l'intérêt national que nous feront
naître avec lui nous constituerons un
gouvernement d'union nationale comme
dans un mariage d'un côté les cadres du
fn de l'autre les soutiens rester aux
côtés de nicolas dupont aignan les
mariés eux tentent d'afficher une
complicité existe c'est une sorte de je
ne sais pas si marine m le terme parce
que chacun sa culture chacun son mais le
comité de salut public pour sauver le
pays avec des gens d'horizons différents
ben voilà on se retrouve on va sauver
notre pays et c'est extraordinaire ce
que nous vivons semaines
auparavant pendant des années vous
rejeté avec force les les thèses et les
incarnations du du front national que
c'était le passé d'abord pour une raison
très simple et je persiste et je signe
marine le pen n'a rien à voir avec jean
marie le pen et vous n'auriez jamais eu
une image avec moi et jean marie le pen
ça vous le savez très bien premier point
deuxième point c'est parce qu'on avait
en face de nous emmanuel macron qui est
le fossoyeur de la france et que l'homme
des oligarques et il y avait je n'ai pas
un mot à retirer d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant ces images parce qu'on
repasse toujours la photo mais on passe
pas le texte et qu'est ce que je dis des
gens d'horizons différents oui nous
sommes d'horizons différents et si vous
repreniez même le discours du 1er mai au
grand meeting qui a eu devant tous les
soutiens de marine le pen j'ai dit je
resterai ce que je suis il n'y aura pas
de fusion j'ai entendu partout fusion
ralliement c'était une alliance mais
ensuite vous avez rompu cet âge est
rompu ça n'a pas marché est jeune et
j'ai continué à ce qu'on avait dit ça a
été dit le divorce après le mariage il
ya eu il y avait pas mariage allianz et
j'avais dit le 1er mai debout la france
restera un parti indépendant gaulliste
avec ses troupes voilà nous sommes
restés ce que nous sommes il ya eu
l'échec qui a eu la vie mais
je pense que ce que j'ai fait à l'époque
ouvrira la porte à des recompositions
politiques parce que emmanuel macron
rassemblant les mondialistes il l'a fait
obligatoirement les patriotes même de
gauche et de droite seront obligés de se
rassembler alors après ils se
rassembleront des recchi comment j'ai
proposé même une primaire en mois de
janvier dernier pour qu'on choisisse
qu'un candidat le meilleur ça n'a pas
marché voilà mais
vous savez j'étais j'ai reçu à la fois
d'immenses manifestations de soutien des
gens du peuple et une telle acrimonie
des gens de l'oligarchie de l'élite qui
pouvait pas accepter
que conçoit libre à partir du moment où
vraiment marine le pen avait abandonné
tout ce qui me répugne est dans
l'idéologie initiale du rassemblement du
front national et donc à partir de ce
moment là tout était clair d'ailleurs la
preuve en est c'est qu'aujourd'hui
marine le pen est beaucoup moins à
droite si on peut dire car eric zemmour
par exemple n'ont que moyennement un
point de rencontre un autre point de
rencontre dans cette mouvance que vous
venez de définir dès 2017 on trouve dans
vos déclarations ce qui sera la kz2
campagne d'eric zemmour vous laisser
partir la thèse du grand remplacement
vous l'assumez vous l'assumez
visiblement vous l'assumez pas
qu'on est en voie si on ne fait rien on
est en voie ce d'un remplacement de
population la vie qui n'est pas bon pour
la population française qu'elles soient
françaises ou étrangers et qui remet en
cause notre modèle républicain donc le
grand emplacement sur une thèse que vous
faites vos mais
ni grand ni absent je je je persiste et
j'ai écrit mais j'ai écrit des livres
j'ai écrit quinze livres 13 livres 12
lynch et même plus j'ai l'impression
d'ailleurs de répéter toujours pareil
dans ses livres
j'ai écrit ce que je pense c'est que
l'immigration peut être une chance quand
elle est assimilée et modérée est
réduite digéré que l'immigration quand
ça devient une submersion devient
remplacement pas grands parce que le
terme du grand remplacement je le réfute
parce qu'il ya un côté complotistes que
c'est organiser et que c'est une vague
sur énorme c'est un remplacement
progressif qui est dangereux pour les
français comme pour les étrangers qui
veulent s'assimiler à la nation et c'est
très intéressant cette scène parce que
c'est toujours la patte il a toujours
pareil qui veut
qui veut pousser dans les consultations
et puis non mais ils posent toujours
séné gros sabots les personnes nées du
hub de tous à dire c'est ça qui est
agréable aujourd'hui c'est que c'est
fini quoi la halle
tous ces gens qui comprennent rien à ce
qui se passe et qui donne des leçons à
longueur de journée toulon s'en fout
heureusement mais c'est pas pour autant
que je vais aller sur une thèse trop
loin par exemple eric zemmour sur la
sphère des prénoms m'a choqué parce que
je suis élu de banlieue je connais plein
de mohamed
2-2 et cetera qui sont des grands
patriotes certains combattu au sel dans
nos armées et c'est pas parce qu'il
s'appelle mohamed qui vont avoir un un
tampon mauvais français ça ça me choque
c'est pas moi donc je pense qu'il ya un
juste milieu à voir dans la défense de
la nation et et surtout dans dans la
cohésion de la nation on peut digérer
une immigration on ne peut pas assimiler
une submersion c'est simple et donc pour
prolonger le échanges qu'on avait tout à
l'heure vous pourriez former la même
façon un comité de salut public avec
eric zemmour tout dépend sur quel
programme d'ailleurs on oublie que sur
avec marine le pen nous avions négocié
dur j'avais fait enlever six points dans
son projet on avait discuté toute une
journée juste après le premier tour et
ça s'était pas fait d'un coup et
notamment il y avait une affaire je sais
pas si vous vous souvenez de l'avs ai
dit que les enfants de clandestins
devaient pas aller à l'école etc enfin
il y avait une polémique pendant le
premier tour et j'avais dit que c'était
pour moi une condition inacceptable d'un
gouvernement et on n'avait jamais fait
enlever ce point là j'avais fait enlever
une taxe sur les importations qui était
délirante parce qu'elle faisait elle
aurait fait à un effet boomerang sur nos
exportations fait des trucs comme ça
donc encore une fois on est dans une
société française où la gauche a le
droit de s'allier et la droite n'a pas
le droit c'est mitterand qui a inventé
ça c'est génial bon moi j'ai beau j'ai
brisé ce tabou maintenant ça veut pas
dire obligatoirement que je vais
m'allier avec tous ceux qui proposent
des choses qui me paraît très excessive
c'est faut discuter voire en tout cas on
n'en est pas là
parce que je pense que l'enjeu déjà
c'est que les français aient le choix et
que justement le système médiatico
politique qui nous gouvernent
ne force pas les français à voter macron
leur présentant toujours disons d des
excès et moi j'ai toujours demandé un
patriotisme on définit comme on veut
républicains raisonnables humaniste
sérieux c'est ce que je défends toujours
se saigne le rpr d'ailleurs d'une
certaine époque autre déclaration cette
fois dans la rubrique zéro pointé
en 2015 quelques semaines après les
attentats de paris vous êtes interrogé
sur le conflit syrien
l'entrée de la russie dans le conflit
syrien est elle une bonne ou une
inquiétante nouvelle d'après vous une
très bonne nouvelle enfin enfin une
action claire nette et urgente
urgente temps où on a traîné sur cette
affaire et je constate qu'il ya qu un
chef d'état dans dans le monde
aujourd'hui c'est de dire mais pour teen
qui assume ses actes et qui a compris le
danger de l'état islamique voilà c'est
tout et à un moment il faut choisir et
on a en face des dirigeants européens ou
américains qui sont complètement hors de
l'histoire au sens au grand sens du mot
histoire est-ce que là la lutte contre
des shu légitime toutes les alliances ou
tous les soutiens y compris en faveur de
vladimir poutine dans l'armée a bombardé
à foix des rebelles modérée des
jihadistes oui et des milliers de civils
côté chic très heureux que vous portent
pas scier ce passage parce que on nous
ressort la phrase sur poutine en ce
moment et dans le contexte où jolie dit
elle était parfaite pourquoi parce que
il ya eu tant de morts sur nos trottoirs
à paris par la faiblesse
des occidentaux qui n'ont pas su
justement choisir et qu'on laissait des
ch tu es tout ça par haine du régime
syrien comme ils ont enlevé saddam
hussein en irak avec un drame où kadhafi
dieu sait si j'ai pas pour kadhafi ni
pour saddam hussein ni pour assad mais
on a laissé le djihadisme envahir
l'afrique parce qu'on a des dingues des
va-t-en-guerre de salon qui ont préféré
des cellules 10 mhz que de soutenir des
chefs d'état qui était pas parfait mais
qui au moins évité le djihadisme voilà
donc moi je maintiens que la russie a eu
raison d'intervenir et que si la france
et les états unis avaient maintenu des
relations avec assad et a été et est
intervenue contre des chemins on
n'aurait pas eu besoin des russes c'est
tout vous savez les occidentaux sont
intervenus et massivement des
occidentaux ils ont armé les islamistes
en voulant armée de modérer syrien les
arbres se sont retrouvés du côté du
djihad en or il ya eu l'intervention
enfin vous une interférence une
intervention on ira très vite après est
en tout cas après les attentats et bien
après et quant aux bars et civils quant
au civil vous avez raison c'est
abominable la guerre mais les américains
quand ils sont intervenus en irak et là
j'avais beaucoup soutenu de villepin
pour ces chiffres américains
bombardaient délibérément des écoles des
zobals et l'américain ont fait d'eux les
russes l'ont fait centaines de milliers
de morts en irak donc ils sont pas
meilleurs que les russes parce que et je
ne les accable pas ils sont partis dans
une logique de guerre effrayante en irak
et moi je si vous voulez je préférerais
qu'on ait un dominique de villepin à
jacques chirac en ce moment qu'un
emmanuel macron mais pas de de
complaisance ou d'admiration
particulièrement mais le régime au laser
poutine nancy vous retrouve si vous
écoutez bien mon extrait et je vous en
remercie je veux le ressortir
dans le contexte y avait rien à redire à
ce que je disais une madeleine à présent
spécialement pour vous
quoi que vous en disiez vous êtes
nicolas dupont aignan un combattant
plutôt solitaire et certains dans votre
entourage vous compare à ce personnage
vous nous direz si vous vous
reconnaissez
à dire mesdames quoi qu'il arrive
vous aurez eu l'honneur de vivre la
minute la plus extraordinaire du siècle
c'est alors que hugh chevalier don
quichotte de la manche s'en fut
conquérir l'univers enfin rossinante
don quichotte ça vous va oui vous savez
si de gaulle avait échoué on l'aurait
appelée don quichotte
ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que la peur du donquichottisme
a entraîné beaucoup de compromission et
de soumission alors c'est tellement
facile de critiquer les gens qui sont
conformes à leurs convictions qu est ce
qu il aurait fallu que je fasse que je
fasse comme les autres que j'abandonne
tous les pans de la souveraineté du pays
pour être sous ministre aux choux farcis
vous savez quand je me
mets pas tout réussi loin de là mais
quand je regarde mon parcours j'ai au
moins la capacité à me regarder dans la
glace sans rougir et j'ai eu une chance
inouïe dans ma vie politique c'est qu'à
chaque fois que j'ai été sur un plateau
de télévision j'ai vraiment dit ce que
je pensais alors on peut être en
désaccord avec moi mais reconnaissez que
au moins une cohérence et et j'imagine
que ça doit tellement être difficile
pour un homme politique de dire
exactement l inverse de ce qu'ils
pensent vous savez quand je me souviens
qu'au moment du vote sur la constitution
européenne je me souviens tellement d'un
député rpr montante dans l'hémicycle et
me disant nicolas j'ai honte de ce que
je vais faire mais je suis obligé sinon
je perds ma circonscription ben moi je
peut-être grâce à ma camionnette que
vous avez vu où les coudes des gens j'ai
eu le soutien populaire de ma
circonscription malgré ce n'était pas
une circonscription favorable à mes
idées
la sincérité après la sincérité et la
fidélité à ses valeurs à ses freins si
vous avez raison c'est primordial oui
après et pas toujours la présence on
peut se demander aussi ayant qu'elle oui
quels sont vos victoires peut-être ma
victoire c'est d'avoir redressé une
ville en faillite d'avoir été maire 22
ans d'avoir complètement magnifier une
vie une petite échelle d'avoir fait
avancer quelques idées le produire en
france avec montebourg regarder ce qui
est d'ailleurs intéressant c'est que les
deux personnalités je trouve qu'ils ont
été les plus honnêtes dans leur combat à
gauche montebourg à droite moi très
prétentieusement bas on n'est pas en
super forme faut être honnête je le dis
pas pour me plaindre c'est dur mais est
ce que ça vaut mieux que d'avoir signé
la reddition du pays et on les voilà en
tout cas moi j'ai envie que les gens
croient encore en la politique
je
suis pas parfait je si c'était à refaire
j'aurais été plus peut-être plus
roublard dans certains moments mais ce
que j'aurais pas perdu aussi ce qui fait
ma force
je préfère des regrets que des remords
et je persiste à penser que j'offre aux
français la seule voie possible pour
redresser le pays voilà j'ai cette
prétention on verra il ya une élection
j'espère qu'on fera le maximum et qu'un
jour ça servira mois pour moi ou un
autre qu importe ce qui compte c'est que
ça serve pour le pays
la rubrique alerte verte c'est une même
archives que nous soumettons à tous les
candidats
une séquence de la campagne officielle
de 74 celle où vous militiez pour chabon
avec un agronome en pull-over rouge qui
tentait de nous alerter et vous savez ce
qui va se passer eh bien nous allons
bientôt manquer de l'eau et c'est
pourquoi je bois devant vous un verre
d'eau précieuse puisque avant la fin du
siècle si nous continuons un tel
débordement elle manquera à lundi je
vous dis au revoir et j'espère vous
revoir pour vous expliquer notre projet
global d'avenir merci mes amis
rené dumont le premier candidat écolo il
avait raison il avait raison et pas
raison à la fois mais il avait raison et
j'ai beaucoup d'admiration pour les gens
de conviction
lui aussi on aurait pu dire qu'il était
don quichotte mais on s'aime toujours
des petites graines qui évolue la preuve
et il a raison c'est un d un des défis
majeurs
simplement on le prend par le mauvais
sens à mon avis voilà c'est à dire que
on se donne bonne conscience alors que
là le seul moyen est ce ce que je
propose de d'éviter l'explorer chauffe
mans climatique et le désert des océans
j'ai fait un rapport là dessus c'est de
mettre fin à la mondialisation inhumaine
c'est à dire de mettre des barrières
douanières de couper avec la chine qui
est en train de de faire exploser la
planète à chaque fois qu'on consomme
allemand ou chinois
on participe du gaz à effet de serre ce
que n'ont pas compris nos écolos et pour
finir une rencontre
rencontre avec françois mitterrand nous
sommes en 1987 lors d'une intervention
du président à la sorbonne
nous sommes français
nos ancêtres les gaulois
un peu romain
un peu germain
un peu juif
un peu italien
espagnol
de plus en plus portugais
peut-être qui sait polonais
et je me demande si déjà nous ne sommes
pas un peu arabe
comment voyez-vous la france nicolas
dupont aignan multiculturel comme
françois mitterrand ou d'abord gauloise
non
multiculturelle
si c'est pour finir comme le liban
ça sera la fin de la france sas est
commune aux murs multiculturelle ci
s'est enrichie d'influencés diverses
mais rester français l'idée la france la
france n'est pas une race c'est pas une
ethnie la france est une idée c'est de
la liberté égalité fraternité
c'est ça la france et le problème
d'aujourd'hui c'est que un excès
de vagues migratoires avec une faiblesse
de l'état et une faiblesse de la
croissance et un abandon de la
souveraineté ça aboutit au liban et je
veux pas de ça et ça ne remet en rien en
cause les personnes c'est tout donc il
faut il faut une il faut une diversité
mais il ne faut pas une négation de ce
qu'on est c'est tout et c'est
l'équilibré entre les deux qui est
important donc mitterrand a affaiblit
considérablement le pays
parce que on peut accueillir du monde si
on a la force à 6 médiatrice et la force
de croissance mais on peut pas à la fois
abandonné la force de croissance la
force d'assimilation et à avoir les bras
ouverts on ne peut pas il faut choisir
gouverner c'est choisir j'étais plutôt
mendès-france que mitterrand au terme de
cet adn et de ce voyage dans nos
archives y at il un un morceau essentiel
de votre adn nicolas dupont aignan que
nous ayons manqué
peut-être le combat social et le combat
féministe
j'ai une mère qui m'a appris beaucoup de
choses et
j'estime que vous parliez de
l'environnement tout à l'heure
je suis toujours un peu choqué que
la défense de l'environnement qui est
utile et remplacer la défense des
injustices sociales
et le sort des femmes et des pauvres et
des miséreux dans le monde
est passé après la défense de notre
planète et or je pense que les deux vont
ensemble
merci nicolas du port et du merci à vous
[Musique]